[Music]
in uh
in granola news
he looked right at me i was like this is
going to be about something indian
that's funny because i looked at you and
said granola and it was all still in
that i knew where you were i knew where
you were leading with this in india tell
me tell me do i need to say in india or
can i just say india
and now you got to say
steve where are you there was a calf
that was born with a third eye on the
forehead and four nostrils and people
are now lining up to worship it that's a
really good thing a calf wait you can't
repeat what yeah like off your leg i
didn't listen to a single word
because i was still thinking about in
india
let me just give you the photo of oh
[ __ ]
whoa
that is so dope
i mean four nostrils i gotta say it's
good this is good wow it's good for the
mythology
this checks out he calls it a mythology
you gotta change that scenario
i'm gonna get killed in the comments for
that one but
yeah i mean people in india are they're
always like this they're like oh you're
born with like a tail you must be
hanuman which is oh yeah like the the
the
just yeah because there's like a
thousand different gods yeah like that
so everything has got to match something
better than american [ __ ] where they're
like jesus is on this potato chip yeah
jesus is in his toast that i [ __ ]
toasted jesus is white
no to that i thought it was funny
jesus jesus looks more like me then
that's true that's korean jesus korean
jesus yeah he's broke dude he's a middle
eastern jew yeah
he looks like a venice surfer
i know right like
jesus that i grew up with i'm like dude
everyone is like you know they're seeing
people in israel and palestine i'm like
he looks like them
but the jesus that i grew up with he
looks like uh like a hipster from
highland park or like yeah yeah long
hair [ __ ] beard but he looks like he
he looks roman jesus he's the roman
jesus you remember back one time we had
a quest christmas party and then our
friend
we knew hollywood jesus have you ever
seen hollywood with jesus so he passed
away but like he used to hang out with
us and we had him at a party i remember
you went hey man that's kind of too far
years ago
years ago you were like you and mike
were like hey this party's dope but i
think that jesus thinks a little too far
i was like dude that's how he looks all
the time
it was a costume party and he dressed
he was the judge of the ugly sweater
competition
jesus was jesus was [ __ ] but people
didn't know that he's like a he's like
an ellie icon and they thought we had a
guy dressed up as jesus oh my god no
this dude he's a comedian like his his
stand-up routine is he's jesus like he
has like a whole thing it was it was
definitely funny
it was very memorable well i'm glad this
cow's getting a good life i'm sure
they're feeding in worshiping otherwise
like in america we would have turned
this this bad boy into a cheeseburger
man give me a two-eyed cow man
you'd be like dude we can get three big
macs from this
just three so does he have like extra
ribs so i can eat it all right so a
unique calf has been born again with
four nostrils and three eyes and locals
believe it is an incarnation of god the
holstein friesian jersey cow was born on
a farm in can you say that go ahead we
got it
where are we right here
dude i don't know where this is
[Laughter]
i'm like dude that says that says
maryland
that was nice
he's trying to indianize it can you read
this baltimore
this says ohio
[Laughter]
your guess is as good as mine all right
i was born and raised in new york so
everything's brooklyn
farmer that claims that many believe
it's the hindu god shiva also known as
the lord of cattle
and pretty much
because you know uh obviously
cows with defects i mean i'm sorry i
want to call it a defect but like uh
cows that or animals they get born with
these are about to [ __ ] you up bro
that's about to [ __ ] you up bro
you're just this is just that's it you
know you just pissed off a billion
people
you're gonna say a girl with two vaginas
is awesome yeah a cow with a third eye
is defective don't bring out old videos
like that dude
they maybe they didn't see the video
they don't know
say i learned this lesson in hardware
now there's an incentive yeah the
callbacks never land yeah i was like the
first week here i was doing massive
callbacks and they were like dude you
need to shut the [ __ ] up we all stared
at you pissed like what the [ __ ] you
weren't even here
neither were you
neither are you it was just you by
yourself
i was just three who was who was here
for my first week i don't know so uh
when the calf was born um they found
four nostrils which further uh
saw the locals thronging our home after
the nocturnal birth the calf is moving
normally and drinks milk from the
mother's udder and makes good use of the
third eye on his forehead to see the
utter
um which is awesome yeah what else would
you do with the third eye
well set things on fire
like lord shiva does
really yeah he's the destroyer so if he
looks at you it's kind of like
sets thing on like yeah yeah if it opens
up he [ __ ] you up oh [ __ ]
on the ocean so it's like indian cyclops
yeah
that's yeah there's three of them
triclop american indian shiva well
cyclops is scott summers american cheese
yeah he's american
locals believe the birth of the animal
will bring villagers good luck and
prosperity with many showering the
animal with gifts such as coconuts and
flowers
that's a dope gift this is a good day
this is not the first calf with multiple
eyes to be born in may 2021
a three-eyed calf arrived in north wales
where it was later slaughtered
location bro location's important
location is everything location is
important born into the wrong country so
although the indian calf is not destined
for slaughter its future is still
uncertain as one livestock department
official believes the animal will not
survive for long because of the defect
because it has a genetic deficiency i
don't want to call it that guys don't be
don't be incessant abnormality they said
these are rare cases but such mutant
animals do not survive for a longer
period they either live for 24 months or
they join the x-men they didn't call it
an x-men they could have called it a god
they should have called it an ex-animal
i have faith this cow's gonna live
longer than that why they always be sick
they always say oh this thing's gonna
die in a couple months and it lives for
more than that so i think i i have faith
well i'll tell you why there's maybe i
mean if unless there's some sort of
medical you know issue with the cow
beyond the complications of having a
third eye which i don't know this cat is
going to live a life of luxury
like all the people are going to like
bring in its food like it's never like
even if they're like we're just going to
set this cow free like no one's going to
kill it they're gonna give it a super
amazing
amazing beautiful life it's just served
everything so it's really like kobe like
when you eat it
right now you're talking about marbles
i bet the milk is like godly
it's sacred milk holy milk what if the
cow just sees fourth dimensionally so
it's constantly freaking out what if
it's in the metaverse because all this
[ __ ]
none of you guys see this yo let's nft
this cap
how do we do this
let's do it let's do it right now yeah
yeah i'm gonna just copy and paste this
i got an nft who owns it does someone
own the cow like this is mine or is it
like a the farmer does the farmer yeah
because i thought like the farmer will
probably try to sell it make some bank
off that's what i'm thinking probably
huh how much do you think you could sell
a special cow like that 10 american
dollars in india is it is it also you
know is it
unsacred to sell cows i'm no [ __ ]
clue
come on
i got a bunch of indian articles here
lined up i know dude
we need connect
and brooklyn can a guy sell a cow really
indeed on this show just speak with an
accent don't say that you don't know
everything will believe
i make up a lot of [ __ ] about japan all
the time do your japanese followers get
pissed no i just like volunteer the
information they think you're an
authority yeah i'm japanese i don't
think they have the ability to ask you
in real time actually
as a japanese american i have to we're
getting some calls let's pick one up
generation indian american
my experience with three-eyed animals is
very very minimal
[Laughter]
on a sunny day do they have a three eye
sunglass
oh yeah or a little umbrella right there
yeah yeah yeah
has anyone been to india have you guys
been i wanna [ __ ] go it's a wild it's
a wild place i mean that in a good way
um
india's i was i was really having uh
incredible time when i'm there i just
remember like being taxied around and
there's just people sitting everywhere
you guys talked there right i did yeah
you're gonna be sitting like sit sitting
on the road there's so many people out
that like people are just sitting on
curbs everywhere yeah it's just there's
people everywhere there's no there's no
like especially in your metropolitan
area it's just it's um
and then every hotel has is gated and
then every single time you come in
they're always checking for bombs under
the cars oh
the mirrors
you got to put all your stuff through
metal detection to get through the glass
doors of the hotel it feels crazy wow
but also feels safe in a weird way but
also feels dangerous it's kind of like
in the philippines they have the same
saying where like if uh any alley that's
dark if you just squint for a couple
seconds you'll just see people chilling
like wow
just sitting there you go oh that looks
empty wait no it's not
you'll just see someone going
[Music]
you